welcome to the alexa prize taskbot
challenge grand finale
[Music]
amazon i like surprise is a set of
university-based challenges we want to
explore and experiment with the latest
and most transformational scientific
advances to help invent the future
generation of ai assistance
we do this by partnering with academic
community
and universities for students to be able
to innovate in tackling some of the most
challenging long-term scientific
problems in ai assistance and
interactive conversational ai the
dashboard challenge is a competition to
let university students build a very
intelligent and helpful voice based
system to help people make decisions or
accomplish tasks such as cooking or
fixing things around the house when
we're talking about ai assistance
is a very
human-like assistance that we are
looking for the goal is ultimately to be
able to build the technology the
conversational ai technology to connect
the successful social blood grant
challenge to really explore different
ways of engaging customers so this is
exactly the kind of interactions that
the task boats are trying to model
all universities all over the world
could participate in alex prize
and we have had many outstanding
universities from europe and asia in
addition to many universities in the
united states we do want to get the best
and brightest people to work on
innovating and exploring new methods and
find diverse ways to see what is really
possible we look for those scientific
advances and turning them into benefits
to alexa customers from around the world
there were 10 teams selected five teams
emerged as the finalists
the five teams are uc santa barbara a
team from the university of pennsylvania
a team from ohio state a team from
university of glasgow in scotland and a
team from portugal ultimately everybody
is working to push forward the state of
the art to improve the taskbar
experience as a whole
alexa
let's work together welcome to the alexa
prize taskbot challenge grand finale
here's one of the finalists hi this is
an alexa prize task bot
i know about cooking and home
improvement
alexa
how can i paint particleboard
sure i found several articles in wikihow
which one do you want let's do the first
one
before we get started please be careful
when using any tools or equipment
remember safety first
part one
step one remove any hardware or
accessories you don't want to paint over
alexa
i did it
step two
sand the board down with 120 grit
sandpaper
the lamination or sheen on the particle
board will prevent paint from sticking
to it
okay
go on coat the particle board with a
layer of oil-based primer the most
difficult part of painting particle
board is getting the paint to adhere to
the surface
alexa next step
step 4
give the primer 30 minutes to an hour to
fully dry
your coat of primer needs to be
completely dry before you can begin
painting the wood
students who are competing in alexa
prize
they have to tackle a number of
challenges that are unique to
conversational and interactive ai what
makes it even extra difficult compared
to many other ai challenges is that
everything has to be done in real time
some of them include just understanding
the intent of what the user wants to do
and be able to interactively guide the
user through instructions in a
multimodal way so that's voice visual
images videos and text
and you present the material in an
engaging and helpful manner
the fact that this is interactive and is
in real time and needs to be engaging
and natural the way human and humans
work together over hundreds of thousands
of years
that makes it extra challenging compared
to many other ai challenges
what kind of paint should i use
oil or lacquer based paints will work
best for painting particle boards
next step
step 2 let the paint dry for 30 minutes
to an hour do you want to know the two
tips for this step
yes please
tip one if you live in a colder or more
humid environment it may take longer for
your paint to dry
it's better to give it more time than it
needs to dry than it is to move on while
the paint is still wet
alexa thanks for that we can continue
step three
apply another coat of paint and let it
dry
alexa tell me some details
with most particle board it will take
between two and four layers of paint to
completely cover the primer
alexa
next step
with your particle board painted and dry
to the touch you can begin putting it
back together
you have reached the end of your project
how awesome
i hope you enjoyed my help with how to
refinish particle board cabinets and you
did it with a robot
thank you
you're welcome
taskbot is particularly challenging
perhaps even more so than socialbot and
that not only the bot needs to keep
track of the state of the conversation
like you would in the socialbot
challenge but also keep track of the
state of the task that the user is
trying to accomplish there was a lot of
variety of how they chose to handle
questions how they choose to handle
navigation and how they choose to
provide the different
visual experience to the users visual
and conversational experiences using the
visual aspect visual output more
strategically or more tactically at each
step is something that absolutely we
want to encourage the teams to do and as
a result the outcomes were somewhat
different based on the emphasis the
teams chose
alexa help me make blondie brownies
do you have any diet constraints
such as vegetarian fish free and peanut
free
alexa i am a vegetarian
i found several blondie brownies recipes
that are vegetarian in whole foods cakes
bee blondie topped brownies cooks
illustrated's blondies and elsa's
brownies alexa let's do cakesby blondie
topped brownies
cakes bee blondie topped brownies looks
appetizing to begin with you will need
to prepare 19 ingredients including for
the brownie layer
let's check if all of them are on your
hand
alexa scroll down
alexa
what kind of nuts should i use for this
recipe
you could use any type of nut you like
alexa can i use a peanut can i use a
pine nut
yes you can use a peanut or a pine nut
in this recipe
alexa
can i substitute light brown sugar for
dark brown sugar
yes you can substitute light brown sugar
for dark brown sugar in this recipe
alexa start cooking
no problem
let's start cooking
step 1 preheat oven to 350 degrees
fahrenheit
alexa next
step two generously grease the bottom
and sides of a large i used a three
quart oblong nine by 16 inch baking pan
alexa
can i use a glass baking pan or do i
need to use a metal baking pan
you can use a glass baking pan but i
would recommend using a metal baking pan
metal conducts heat better than glass so
your blondies will likely bake more
evenly in a metal pan
alexa next step
evaluating the ai and evaluating the
interactions and real time engagement
with the ao assistant is very very
difficult and challenging at amazon we
take it very seriously evaluating the
teams and their performance during the
finals we want to make sure it's fair
and transparent
the judges are kept in separate location
the only thing they can hear and see is
the actual bot and that's really
important so they can be an independent
judge focusing only on that conversation
in completing the task strict rules that
we have and we maintain throughout the
finals
step one out of four
grease pan with butter
alexa remind me what kind of butter
salted or unsalted
i would recommend using unsalted butter
for this recipe
alexa can i substitute anything for the
butter
yes you can substitute margarine or
another type of butter for the butter in
this recipe
alexa what kind of flour should i use
great question
i don't know the answer but i don't want
that to slow us down
i'm really keen to keep going
alexa next one of the things we
discovered just how important it is for
the system to sometimes take initiative
and not to passively wait for a user to
express their interest and you can see
this throughout the competition that the
bots are driving the conversation
forward and not just passively waiting
for instructions
what i learned from just observing the
bots is how
tiny details can completely derail an
otherwise really intelligent smart bot
the users will surprise us constantly
asking for things that deviates from the
expected responses and it's really hard
to recover from that step 11
bake until top is shiny cracked and
light golden brown 22 to 25 minutes do
not over bake
alexa how can i tell when my brownies
are done
step 12
this is the last step go to previous
step
step 11
bake until top is shiny how can i tell
that my brownies are done
step 12 alexa
what are the adjustments for high
altitude baking
there are a couple of things you can do
to help with this
the first is to make sure your oven is
at the correct temperature if you have a
thermometer you should be able to
measure the temperature of the oven and
adjust the baking time accordingly
another thing to consider is the
humidity at higher altitudes the air is
drier so you will need to add more
moisture to your baked goods to keep
them from drying out this can be done by
adding more baking soda or baking powder
or by increasing the amount of water in
your recipe
alexa next step
step 12
this is the last step of this recipe
remove bars from pan by lifting foil
overhang and transfer to cutting board
cut into two inch squares and serve
excellent work
hope you had fun with me today
say finished if you're all done for now
finished
okay thanks for chatting
bye some of the innovations that blew me
away were just how much the state of the
art has come in natural language
understanding and in question answering
what blew me away is just how
intelligent some of the bots are at
answering questions they can really
answer difficult questions correctly in
the context of the task like can you
replace a particular kind of baking pan
from a glass to the metal or can you
replace particular kind of nuts with
another kind of nuts sort of doing
actually pretty pretty difficult
reasoning so well that it almost seems
like magic right it seems almost like
wizardry where really what's going on
underneath is fairly sophisticated
language models and ingesting knowledge
sources and aggregating it to pull out
just the right answer at the right time
to the user
alexa
help me plan a birthday party
here are some results for plan a
birthday party courtesy wikihow the top
results are how to plan a birthday party
for a friend how to plan a birthday
party and how to celebrate a 90th
birthday party let's do the third one
sure i can help with how to celebrate a
90th birthday party
step 1 of 20
recognize if your guest of honor is
mobile or requires assistance consider
both the guest of honor and his or her
friends
good suggestion
next step
step 2 of 20
consider transportation to and from the
party
many though not all 90 year olds no
longer drive their own vehicles on a
daily basis next step
step 3 of 20 remember the interests of
the honored guest
while you are planning a 90th birthday
party it does not have to be solely
focused on the number 90. instead think
of the current or past interests of your
honoree and see if you can incorporate
these into the party this is a great
opportunity to be creative
one of the key objectives of amazon
alexa prize is to build a robust
community from students and faculty
researchers and ai scientists and
engineers at amazon we do want the best
talents wherever they are to be able to
come and contribute and innovate
we're continuously looking for new
innovations and be able to get
inspirations from all the work that has
been done in alex surprise
step 18 of 20 prepare the guest of honor
on the day of the party it may be
appreciated to help prepare your guest
of honor for their special day by going
out of your way to make sure they feel
their best if the honoree is a woman
consider taking her to get her hair done
or nails painted before the party these
simple beauty splurges can make her feel
special on her special day
what is another example of something i
can do to help them feel special
decorate for the party many card stores
or party stores will sell 90th birthday
themed items
even a simple hat for the honoree can
make them feel special
what kind of hat
a hat that can make them feel special
should we resume working on the task
yes
step 19 of 20
give a toast
attending their 90th birthday party is a
great time to let the guest of honor
know how much he or she means to you
make it a true toast
you don't want to be left with a silent
room when you propose toasting your
honored guest
that makes sense next step
this is the last step
create a souvenir book
this will help your honoree to remember
his or her special day
ask all in attendance to sign the book
and to leave a little message to the
birthday celebrant
contact those who will be attending
beforehand
and ask them to bring a favorite picture
or a favorite letter to put in the book
when you're finished you can say
complete to finish the task
complete
nice job it was a pleasure working with
you
the alexa prize provides a really
valuable experience to the students
and faculty but mostly the students who
get experience working with real
customers process thousands of
conversations get the freedom to really
explore different ways of engaging
customers to run experiments on real
data to work with it speeds up
innovation
the wide variety of amazon customers
that engage with the bots is just not
possible to find in a lab right it's
impossible to recruit you know 20 people
to represent the variety or diversity of
the people that interact with the bot
there is no substitute for experience
with working with real users
and real data
alexa let's make beef chao fun do you
have the recipe
here's what i found in whole foods
market for beef chow fun
the top options are beef chow fun and
beef chow fun beef ho fun
alexa i'd like to make the first one
couldn't have made a better choice
myself
the recipe beef ciao fun has a 3.7 star
rating
takes about 30 minutes
and serves four
what is a recipe without its ingredients
alexa tell me the ingredients
beef chow fun uses so many ingredients
you'll feel like a true chef it has 16
ingredients but i am sure it is worth it
they are on the screen
alexa what's the difference between soy
sauce and dark soy sauce
dark soy sauce is made from soy beans
that have been fermented for a longer
period of time
it has a higher concentration of soybean
oil which is what gives it its dark
color
soy sauce made with regular soy beans is
called regular soy and is often used in
asian cuisines such as japanese and
korean
give me another fun fact
okay i also love fun facts
here it goes microwaving is the
healthiest way to cook vegetables
i love sharing these facts alexa why is
microwaving the healthiest way to cook
vegetables
microwaves don't heat the food they heat
up the water molecules in it this causes
them to vibrate which is what causes the
heat this vibration is good for your
body because it causes your cells to
produce more energy to continue working
say resume our next step
i am sure you are doing a stellar job
next step
although we call alex surprise
competition
in my view is really a co-op petition
it's really amazing to see them achieve
so much in a short time they have been
inspiring to many people as they learn
and grow and contribute to say the art
in conversational ai at the end of the
day it's really a competition for
collaboration cooperation and competing
together
step 11
then add in the noodles and the sauce
mix at the same time and stir the
noodles with the sauce
use the sauce to soften up the noodles
more and keep moving the noodles around
so it doesn't sit too long against the
pan else it might stick to it cook it
for about one to two minutes or until it
looks soft
alexa should i worry about overcooking
the noodles
no you don't need to worry about
overcooking the noodles
just be sure to follow the recipe
instructions and you'll be fine
after all cooking is all about trial and
error
so go ahead and experiment
alexa continue
step 12
throw in the bean sprouts and green
onions and the cooked beef and quickly
toss it into the noodles and turn off
the heat
alexa next step
step 13
continue to toss everything together and
let the bean sprouts and green onions
cook with the residual heat from the pan
remove from pan serve and enjoy
alexa can i cook it and serve it the
next day
yes you can cook it the next day
how are the bean sprouts coming along
the bean sprouts are doing well
alexa should i use fresh bean sprouts if
i cook it the next day
i would recommend using fresh bean
sprouts if you cook it the next day they
will have a better flavor and texture
alexa is there anything else you can
tell me about this recipe that might
make it more fun to prepare or serve to
my guests
well one fun way to serve this recipe is
to make it into a fun and festive dish
for example you could turn it into a
halloween themed meal by adding some
spooky
decorations i had fun working with you
today
i hope i can help you again soon okay
thanks for chatting
bye
so this was the first year of taskbot
and the teams did a great job
over the past five years there has been
tremendous amount of transformational
scientific advances as a result of alex
surprise
ai and in particular conversational ai
and ai assistance is going to benefit
the humankind
this is a really unique once in a
lifetime opportunity for university
students to participate and help invent
the future of ai assistance
[Music]
[Music]
you